we do have our rather spectacular black
lesbian press secretary Karin
Jean-Pierre and uh she doesn't like that
Elon Musk isn't Towing the line that
Elon must dare have thoughts related to
Anthony fauci did you know um Elon Musk
who launched a series of attacks on Dr
Anthony fauci over the weekend calling
for his prosecution and then he shared
some other memes about him and suggested
he lied about he's lying about the
origins of the coronavirus what's what's
your response uh first of all to
specifically to the attacks on uh Dr
fauci so look we've been very clear
about this these attacks these personal
attacks that we have been seeing are
dangerous on Dr fauci and other public
health professionals as well are they
are disgusting and they are divorced
from uh from reality and we will
continue to call that out and be very
clear about that again these are
incredibly dangerous these personal
attacks that we are seeing lady lady you
are dangerous you are disgusting you are
divorced from reality not Elon Musk who
is looking at the evidence that I think
we've laid out a fairly decent case
today to show you who was lying the
entire time and who actually cares about
science so no one should care what
Korean Jean-Pierre says uh she is a
agent of a regime that is built on lies
that's all she is I would say she is
also lizard person adjacent much like
fauci and everything else they're all in
on it together right so their whole
their whole existence is connected so
they can't basically walk from it
because if you walk from it the machine
will turn turn on you it's basically a
giant game of Russian Roulette and
everyone's just waiting to see who who
shoots first who who's actually going to
jump ship first and say boy it does you
know what actually yeah the
administration was coordinating with big
Tech and we did Silence dissent and we
did censor people and everything else